nell'episodio precedente che la sinistra
che cazzo vuoi giro a testa gira a
destra gila aiuto aiuto
sì io avevo allora faremo questo
cazzo ok ok ok ok ok via via vennero
spostati o l'on
ok ragazzi quello quello non lo sapevo
non lo sapevo lo sapevo lo sapevo che
andrà a finire così
lo sapevo che andavano da solo non può
esistere esistiamo solo se tutti insieme
cliff fix ii che cazzo state facendo
ragazzi ragazzi un uomo sexy si sta
avvicinando al mio culo non è norma cosa
fanno
ragazzi sulle mani per il genchi dama
ragazzi già possiamo fare a sconfiggere
pif così solo dove sono ragazzi che cosa
così cosa cazzo successo tu con scuse st
oddo rega aiuto sono stato trasportato
nel mondo lire caio forse niente panico
questo posto nella tua mente essere
umano se conosci te stesso non devi
temere nulla devo mettere alla prova la
tua rabbia c'è il genio romano non è
unito come me con una con una simile
massa di individui arrabbiati non mi
stupisco che abbiate tutti i migrazioni
diverse questa è una citazione che
condivido in pieno la mia inter entità
si muove all'unisono e per questo motivo
solo ho vinto contro chi mi disturbava
esaminerò quale direzione prendete così
voi avete le vostre risposte ragazzi che
cazzo dove devo prendere una direzione
non sta diventando tutto bianco sono
morti in poche parole forse credo non lo
so spero di no
sono vivo svegliate a svegliare addio
tutto a posto è semplicemente la sbornia
del sabato sera ci siamo è chiuso no non
lo so più
mica se in botta pesante lo dico io
spranga di ferro ragazzi ce la posso
fare
brucia ancora tutto non posso farcela
sono troppo lontano
mica se ubriaco forte amico mio ragazzi
che cazzo succede vi pensare con
lucidità action aborto a cui pensa
troppo l'unesco a sollevarlo mai con la
spranga laico la spranga a qualcosa
certo fantastico non mi pare sicuro ma
chi cazzo se ne frega ragazzi stacco
tanto ormai abbiamo passato i posti più
insensati quindi non meno
è un cazzo di cosa sicura o meno
perfetto come non detto ragazzi abbiamo
l'abbiamo presa nel caveau anzi in una
maniera incredibile
non sto andando bene una specie di test
e la via più ovvia forse non è quella
giusta
aran ho capito un cazzo
forse allora facciamo così prendo la
spranga prendo la sega a caso devo
pensare con lucino allora che cazzo devo
fare non so è chiusa non ci ho provato
20 volta però come funzioneranno
funziona ragazzi un enigma perfetto
adesso toccherà testé rete con mano la
genialità di fa vige lo sapevo lo sapevo
sono un genio sono un cazzo di genio non
lavora anche visto questo ed è di qui
passami con la pipa mico forse posso
farti uscire di qui dai non ci rimane
molto tempo mica noi non ci posso
credere
duro su quello che volete che non ho
guardato soluzioni è andato al culo
c'è un buco nel muro riesco a vedere
un'altra cella dove passare la pipa
cos'è la pira spranga semmai ok magari
ma la dà in testa sono sicuro che non è
ok stai qui tornerò ma bene fai quello
che vuoi amico mio io ti aspetto
se prova a entrare qualcuno li visse
sono indebita amico buona fortuna buona
fortuna cosa aprista porta testa di
cazzo apri la porta
bravo ok ci ha pensato un mattone
effettivamente ho fatta se ce l'ho fatta
fantastico cioè non so se sono io ad
aver bevuto prima gli aveva fatto storia
in play o cosa ma non l'importo
ricchezza sia sono ancora nella mia
testa
ok allora andiamo avanti di coach è una
c'è un
non lo so se tirarlo anomalo tiro perché
perché sono figo ok mi sa che ho
peggiorato la situazione regalo so che
cazzo è successo ma non importa
cos'è sta roba
ami fama ha visto danneggiando da solo
fantastico ok ok non avevo visto film
non avevo visto tranquilli tranquilli
tranquilli tranquilli tranquilli lancio
mori forse così muore forse così muore
si gioca zucca stronzo è morto ucciso
pista non ci posso credere
sei vivo ucciso più si è ucciso tecnica
incredibile ragazzi è il giorno più
bello della mia vita
giuro non è possibile ci posso credere
sono sono contentissimo e fantastico
ucciso uno stronzo di merda che meritava
la morte già da secoli e ho suonato le
campane bellissimo
adesso lo suonato le campane che caso
sono un nuovo prete della città fatemi
capire la porta è chiusa ma sembra
debole forse per te provare a sfondarla
va bene allora datemi qualcosa pif dammi
una mano
tirana testa forse potevo cosa ma non da
solo
grazie succeda forse non dovevo uscire
piccola ragazzi credo di aver capito
però non allora pip
io non ti faccio un cazzo però tu mi dai
una mano ok
perché non si può far le cose da soli va
bene perché se non finisco male facciamo
così io tiro questa quel segnale sembra
un richiamo chissà se il mio amico
laggiù risponderà amico mio io sono solo
un amico sono aspetta la metà allora non
sente un cazzo sto qui il richiamo non
lo capisce da mais è messo a correre
ragazzi ragazzi ap la porta non apre la
porta è stronzo è stronzo fino al
midollo scopi
perché c'è la voglia di merda che sei
doveva si si si apri bastardo apre si
sfigati addio
minchia non ci posso credere sei un
grande e pif sei un cazzo di fenomeno io
ti volevo bene all'inizio ci sembra che
io ce l'abbia ce l'abbia avuta con te
per tutto il tempo ma in realtà ti
volevo bene a parte tutte enigmatica che
il colle nemici ci azzecco mai meno di
mia nonna
sono sollevato umani in creature come
voi l'egoismo sarebbe catastrofico avete
dimostrato di poter pensare finire
elevato la vostra posizione
abbiamo ci chiamano fa il j per un
motivo a zio rivelerò qualche rivelata
howard rivela mi qualche caso vuoi a
perfetto che deve deve spara flash armi
roba in faccia però questo non lo
continuerò a capire sono nuoto pugliese
in questo luogo mi molti milioni di anni
fa ancor prima che acer normale
esistesse ragazzi sono in modo vero
prima l'umanità che mi chiede svariati
nomi il demone spirito quello che bella
frase amico mio solo che si è aperta la
porta manita creò questo posto ragazzi
che cazzo è successo e mi trovo
mettendomi a tacere profanarono il mio
luogo di pace e decisori distrugge mio
senza alcun mezzo di difesa fu costretto
ad attaccare
non sono io il barbaro e nemmeno un
invasore voi lo siete
ok effettivamente l'essere umano e più
merda di quanto pensassi
però questo mi apre le porte silenzio
prima faceva un casino della madonna
adesso la emi ha tolto il computer che
cazzo sei mia madre
tu mano se diverso mai dimostrato allora
io ti chiedo pietà non permettere che
venga distrutto la tua razza lo
farebbero di certo hanno seguito linux
fin qui e tu hai seguito loro
distruggerai tutte le tracce di questo
posto così che nessun essere umano mi
scoprirà di nuovo lo faresti per me lo
faccio io lo faccio io
non c'è problema non c'è faccio tutto io
guarda c'è anche facebook condivido io
so per distruggere tutto prima di prima
condivide poi lo faccio che ai normali
esegui mapex scrivi mi servono alcune
cose da te cose che questo è l'inizio
non so cosa devo fare devo pensare
pensare pensare ragazzi dobbiamo
dobbiamo distruggere o giuro oam sto
amando questo gioco perché a parte tutto
c'è una storia meravigliosa dietro c'è
giuro non si sposta ok devo proprio
andarmene da qui ho capito che
continuano sti flash sono necessari mio
dio che adesso vedo più un cazzo
però la torcia c'è ok lega mi sono
sparite muri ok allora è il computer mi
rimane no non ancora devo pensare che
cazzo penso che mi si smantella al muro
di st non c'è un cazzo buttò libro giu
ok idea di merda non posso neanche la
matita neanche la matita i libri il
sapere è una merda quindi non serve
bengala i segnali luminosi tipo e si
così non gli ho mai usati non servono un
caso tanto ormai è finito ti stia punti
cosa stanno significando cosa cosa è
successo
anch'esso moore è andato a [ __ ]
fantastico rimane non so cosa devo fare
o pensare pensare pensare ho capito un
calendario dell'anno scorso non ne sono
certo che hanno è dove sono mi sono
spariti muri vi rimane soltanto il
pavimento effettivamente al soffitto non
è anche soffitto andato a [ __ ] pure
quello che vai vai su facebook lei su
facebook vi sono sparite i muri
condividi
lo farei per me mi chiese e io risposi
di sì siamo fortunati quando leggerai
questa mail sarò morto
minchia che ottimismo il caso contrario
moriremo tutti
la miniera nord occidentale si trova
nell anno gli ha dato le coordinate
perfetto uccide le uccidere tutti
ragazzi ho scritto questa mail cioè devo
messaggio inviato da un miglio che
finisce così no non può finire così
ragazzi non può finire così non può
finire così
ditemi che c'è un sequel ditemi che c'è
un cazzo di segue ho finito penombra
black flag è stato fantastico ci ho
capito le relativamente poco più o meno
capito io la butto molto sorridere su
ste cose però più o meno cerco di capire
la storia ho capito più o meno perché
alla fine qualcuno cosa mi sono tornate
qui si fa come la spiega bene magari lo
sa che la capisco meglio comunque spero
che abbiate capito un po più di corse di
me perché comunque come gioco e anche
poetico io posso dire di aver finito uno
dei giochi più fantastici che abbiamo
iniziato e che ho concluso dopo un anno
perché avevo perso i salvataggi eccetera
ma sono orgoglioso di esserci riuscito è
che i miei ragazzi
spero che vi do vi sia piaciuto fatemi
sapere cosa ne pensate nei commenti come
al solito ragazzi 6 video è piaciuto al
suo documento mi piace anche a pagina di
facebook come ogni video frate nella
descrizione bene se ne faresti stranieri
ci vediamo l'occasione belle ragazze